I don't think there's anything we can do
about it because he was your boyfriend
shut the F up UFA you only have three
months to live when I went to the doctor
and he said I only had three more months
to live
and it was five months ago so I'm
waiting I have a rare type of tumor
[Music]
I'm Oh bleep new Foreman it's a like a
blood blood tumor blood cancer the life
spectin see it's very locally I was at a
party and I I had been given a lot of
alcohol and I had ended up in the
hospital and they decided to perform a
rape kit on me and the police officer
told me I don't think there's anything
we can do about this because he was your
boyfriend and juries don't usually go
for convictions when it's someone you
trust
growing up you just you look back and
you reflect and you think hi there's
there's things that like they hop into
you but they make you stronger as a
person so you kind of have to take it as
a learning learning tool and just move
on and know that you're stronger because
of it I think I was in fourth grade I
was on the school bus I was talking to
my friend and he was just like shut the
F
[Music]
a while back my father and I got into a
pretty intense argument and he told me
that he was skinless shame to have me as
his son and that really hit me you know
harder and it's to this day I still
think about that and use that to kind of
motivate me to be better and try to
build a relationship with them again
that's why aren't you smart enough
and he says that my mother I was working
on math homework and I was probably in
fourth grade and I can figure out a
question and she straight up asked me
that and now that I have him I would
never say that to my kid ever
I was in Mississippi in 1996 a place
called Moss Point a little Caucasian boy
with his father called me the n-word
inside of McDonald's the most painful
thing he wanted ever said to them dad
didn't say anything matter of fact it
was kind of crazy
taught more mad at the dead and I was
the most painful thing anyone has ever
said to me is it's okay you're gay but
you have time to change that being away
from you has been so good for me
in my mental health I can't spend time
with you sky how bad your mental health
is makes me just a tiring person to be
around I don't love you I'm no longer
love you let's just be friends I love
you but you're not what I want
[Music]
it wasn't real no one could ever love
your two broken
it was kind of a way for him to
make me feel trapped in the relationship
because nobody could ever love me
I would accept what he was giving me
which wasn't love like breaking out you
know a few tears fell down you know
that's it you know I didn't I didn't
know how to really got that I don't want
to start crying I you should be grateful
that I'm even doing you attention
because you're fat no one will love you
anyway a guy that I was dating tried to
go too far you where next year my dad
like he was playing but that I can make
a like a mark in my life so what's the
most people think someone is said to you
but I was going to lose my left leg
you're too loud made me feel like scared
to be myself and like I needed to hide
Who I am as a person
I was in third grade and there was this
girl who I think was the end of the year
his girl who I liked I overheard her
talking with one of her friends and like
oh do you like to be like Dan and she's
like nah no he's fat and she didn't know
I was there and you know I saw it
and but it just stayed stayed with me
and was I remember just being totally
crushed one of my students asked me why
I was even a teacher because I wasn't
like because I was failing at my job I
think I might get my own kids
just yeah why are you even here
I didn't know anyone at my new school is
in third grade
this boy name is Scott you're watching
he walked by my desk skinny tap my notes
to get my attention and he pointed me he
said you're stupid thank you cried and I
want to go to school for a while and the
teacher didn't notice
I always wear I would
just growing up my dad told me that I
would never do anything and that I would
never be able to do anything and I could
never leave the house that I grew up in
I left obviously and now I'm doing great
things and not helping other people so I
proved him wrong and we'll work on that
probably something my dad has said to me
because he said some really not nice
things to me before we go you see
through them for you that's my sister
yeah yeah we're actually all sisters
triplets so so she was saying like I'm
curious to see what your answer would be
because she probably might have had
simple answer to me my other sister
might have us actually know I think I
might change my answer because okay so
my mom and I have always been really
close but I went through a hard time you
know when I was like in high school and
she was kind of like the person I leaned
on to help me through it
and at one point she was like I was
complaining to her about the thing I was
going through I was sick I was in the
hospital so that's why I was complaining
it wasn't like my boyfriend worked out
with me or her
um and she was like had like stop
complaining I'm so sick of you and I
didn't expect her to say that and it
made me so upset and I didn't I mean we
didn't have the same relationship for
like years after that but I think it
hurt me the most didn't expected to come
to her
so even though I expect my dad to say
something mean mean you know what I mean
like he's just kind of these dishes that
way so it just hurt as much but when he
came from her I was like that hurt so
that's that's where the worst I'm sick
of you I used to have really bad acne
and so I had a lot of starring and I
remember one day I wanted to work
without makeup and my boss told me oh
you know like like you do drugs like
you've been picking at your face and it
was so painful for me and beyond that
point that's when I became obsessed with
makeup and I couldn't for a long time I
couldn't go to the hospitai makeup and
even now I still struggle going out of
the house with makeup but I feel like
slowly I'm gonna kill
and slowly the words will just become
meaningless but they were very impactful
to me and still continue to be impactful
to me I was in the inner garden and I
was in love with my kindergarten teacher
thought she was just coolest thing but
whether the Hall monitors came in to
give her a message and I saw her because
I knew the hall monitor and I said hi
so-and-so and then I heard the teacher
look at her and say oh you know that's a
black thing changed me forever it didn't
like her anymore it hurt my feelings but
it didn't stop me from loving people so
I think the most painful thing someone
said to me is that my face is bad
because I have really big cheeks and I
saw but yeah they didn't like that so
they were like your face is fast that's
kind of hurtful to me because I felt
like that was my trademark like you know
my cheeks are my trademark so well
somebody called me the B word in front
of like a lot of people like on social
media
and she didn't like over the name or
anything it caused a lot of people to
have like a different work on me so when
I was little and like babe there's these
kids because I used to help making out
with boys like I like play basketball
and things like that and then this like
what they used to say that like
you just said that I was a boy
because I'm a boy it's just really
annoying and I haven't spoken to my dad
in about eight months so I called him
and he said he was at work he works
abroad and he said I'm at work right now
I'm gonna call you later
and that was about seven months ago and
I never got a call back so I'd say in
retrospect that is like a hard pill to
swallow so that would be my answer this
kid named ebony called me a paid either
way
how'd it make you feel it made me feel
really sad like really oh so my dad had
passed away in like 2009 and I was being
really mean to this girl and I was like
nine years old and then she's like
that's why your dad died because I was
being mean to her so that's the meanest
thing sort of said to you know we don't
want you around anymore I was like 13
and I had like really cool neighbors
that I love very much and I couldn't be
at home because at home was hard
and they were like my home my home for
me but then it was just too much for
them they already had a family and it
was too much to take on somebody else
who even just hung around that was
probably the most painful thing I've
ever experienced you know but it did
teach me a lot it teach me a lot about
how they can help me myself my
ex-husband was a drug addict alcoholic
and he was extremely emotionally and
mentally and verbally abusive as well as
physically abusive and he used to tell
me all the time that I'm stupid and
that's 100% the most painful thing
anyone can say to me because I pride
myself on my intellect and my
intelligence and it's the thing that I
think I'm best at so that's he knew that
was the thing that would get me so he
would say it almost daily you're stupid
you're stupid you're stupid the most
painful thing that anyone has ever said
to me I was 12 I had an accident
my grandfather was driving a boat when
my leg got hit by the propeller my
grandmother told said yelled at when
they were bringing me up to the back of
the house after the accident and she
said who in the broad heard
thank you yeah thank you well I think I
do feel better hey guys thanks for
watching another episode if you haven't
subscribed to my channel yet and you
want to subscribe to my channel please
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and a little ball next to it so you'll
get notified every time I put up a new
episode and if you really really like my
episodes and you have some friends that
you think might also like the episodes
it would mean a lot if you shared my
episodes with them as well if you want
soon that's pretty much it thank you
guys again and I'll see you next week
you